trippy is more than just a Black Tusk
soldier that makes the sound of a
disgruntled chicken she is a dangerous
and unpredictable foe that needs to be
stopped before she is able to take more
of a hold of the districts of Washington
DC
[Music]
[Music]
to the untrained eye Sandra Patterson
comes across as Meek dainty and beakable
Lex old delicate bird who in one swift
move could be broken and easily
discarded yet beneath the surface lies a
cold calculated and Psychopathic Hunter
with a brutality and disregard of life
that has awarded her with the honorable
title of the highest kill count of any
Black Tusk member a deadly sniper she is
an expert in field craft navigation and
stealth she is intelligent and extremely
patient which makes for a dangerous
combination when paired with her
outstanding abilities and Marksmanship
known for preferring to actively hunt
her targets at night comfortably perched
in the vegetation high above her
unsuspecting prey or deep in the shadows
of a bush she is roosting in her element
ready to pounce
soon the nickname chirpy was bestowed
upon her rumored to be seated by the way
in which a victims never saw her coming
and were only alerted to her presence
when it was already too late
the chirps sound omitted as the lead
bullet took flight through the silencer
was the last conscious awareness that
her victims retained before they were
permanently eliminated
at the initial outbreak of the green
poison she was already on active duty
with the Army and with the impressive
body count that chippy had already
racked up she was obviously considered a
highly valuable asset to a company like
the Black Tusk and so unsurprisingly was
nested to their organization soon after
I wonder if chirpy games and how she
deals with fatigue at the end of the day
I mean do you ever find that after a
hard day of physical work in the mines
or construction industry or something
that you can barely lift your arms and
even the weight of the mouse is too much
to take on severely hindering your
gaming time
well me either but I don't exactly have
the manliest of jobs I sit in an office
all day the most strenuous thing I do is
probably the walk from my car to my desk
but I still get tired especially if I
don't get my afternoon nap
well Logitech has taken the iconic g502
and managed to reduce its weight to an
impressive 89 grams in the new g502 X
Plus but this isn't the only upgrade
the g502 has been my go-to mouse for the
last several years for me and my giant
mouse destroying hands this sturdy Beast
has been one of the few around that has
managed to survive past the first few
months of use so when they told me about
the 502x plus I was pretty excited to
try it out straight away I noticed the
reduced latency due to the light Force
hybrid switches and an updated light
speed protocol this was actually more
obvious than I was expecting
I'll admit it felt a little odd when I
first took it out of the box as this
mouse is just so damn light but once I
started gaming I very quickly forgot
about this and actually really noticed
the advantage of list drag especially
with the hero 25k Advanced sensor
delivering the performance power and
precision we've all come to expect with
the Logitech G range
and the new LED band I've always said if
you don't have enough LED lights
streaming out through the window to
light up the driveway enough to land a
plane you're doing it wrong anyway a big
thank you to Logitech for sponsoring the
video
leading on from previous targets of this
Manhunt General Anderson is attempting
to migrate the true Sons towards the
Black Tusk and now he is beginning to
see the repercussions of this
I need your help Natalia already you
were right about Lewis he's not acting
alone and I'm worried if we might have a
mutiny on our hands how many defectors
so far uh 10 maybe 20. be patient he's
turning my men against me if they are so
easily turned they were never your men
what do you suggest I do be patient
keep watch can you help me watch him of
course
this isn't exactly a good look for
Anderson for affection that is
attempting to sell their case for why
the black tusks should trust and take
them on board this only makes them look
weak as well as raising the question of
whether he is suitable as a leader
Natalia and Anderson are now more than
aware of where Captain Lewis has perched
but before acting on it Anderson
questions Lewis directly in an attempt
to see where his loyalties lie
to the cause I'd never been more
committed to the cause sir I hear things
have been tense between you and trick
I wouldn't say tense I just personally
don't care for the man what did he do to
offend you Captain you didn't really do
anything
he called me a triangle
that was weird but I wouldn't call it
offensive
he's just odd and makes me uncomfortable
you seem to be uncomfortable a lot
lately
I don't really understand why we were
working with the Black Tusk yesterday we
were killing each other and today I'm
supposed to trust trig to have my back
do you trust me
of course then don't worry about the why
just get the job done
give the Black Tusk whatever they need
to secure this Alliance copy that
unsatisfied with Lewis's response
Anderson egg Zone like Tusk operative
chirpy asking her to do what is required
to remove Lewis from the equation and
find out who else is involved
big Lewis into custody and bring him to
Fairview do you want him to know he is
in custody what do you mean I mean I
could bring him in and he could know
he's being brought in or I could just
bring him in and he will have no idea we
are on to him ah handle but not control
yeah sure
maybe we can uncover some more rats
exactly thank you chirpy no problem
General yeah out of curiosity why do
they call you chirpy
Jesus Christ uh thank you I understand
why they call you chirpy
all right
before this could happen there was one
not so small problem coming her way
shd agents would find out that chirpy
was active in downtown East Washington
DC
trippy's gaggle of Black Tusk forces
have taken a large number of strategic
locations across the district agents
waste little time in fighting through
the hordes of black dust soldiers
breaking the outposts down one by one
eventually they would learn of chuppi's
location around Washington hotel
the Black Tusk had well established
themselves in this facility evidence of
their occupation can be found all over
the site
and classic Black Tusk style there were
warhounds and midi tanks fouling every
turn but the agents were able to fight
through and would eventually find chirpy
in the ballroom surrounded by guards
while her deadly pinpoint accuracy and
super annoying drone roofed unpleasant
and a right burden she was the very
definition of glass Cannon and after a
lot of attempts once focused she would
quickly be taken down
this target leads a fairly linear Story
Only reinforcing what has been suspected
with Captain Lewis and General Anderson
up until now
Lewis has all been announced his future
with the true Sons under the leadership
of Anderson
the decision to join with the black task
has sent Lewis to question the direction
of this once proud faction with this
target literally been asked to sort
Louis out I expect in the next Target or
the main target to show Lewis either
escaping the group or being taken into
custody but we shall find out soon
I don't know if I did something wrong
but there didn't seem to be any
additions to the many Lewis comms in
this Manhunt Target so maybe we'll be
seeing a little more in the next or
maybe I just need to nail gun Kelso to
the basement floor the next time I see
her so I can get the new Intel
anyway because I'm a dad and I hold on
to my god-given right and societal
expectation to use dad jokes and puns I
have used exactly 25 bird related words
in this video some more obvious than
others I guarantee you won't find them
all mainly because of my poor grasp of
the English language but let me know how
many you find otherwise thank you very
much for watching and I'll catch you in
the next one
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]